a red dragon makes her debut and a green
gown stops the show and both have more
meaning than you might think episode 5
of House of the Dragon was way more than
just those gnarly nuptials throughout
House of the Dragon in the book it's
based on George R.R Martin's Fire and
Blood Prince Damon Targaryen calls his
wife lady Ria Royce his bronze Damon and
Ria's marriage isn't a happy one to say
the least it's not even much of a
marriage we find out in episode 5 they
are yet to consummate their Union and
Damon spends little to no time in his
wife's Homeland the veil so why does he
call her bronze house Royce ruled as
bronze Kings until house Aaron assumed
power during The andal Invasion their
flag is a bronze Square framed by
ancient rooms and they wear bronze armor
as those Rio when she goes hunting in
episode 5 why Damon dislikes her so much
just left to the reader's imagination as
are the circumstances of her death in
Martin's writing she dies nine days
after hitting her head against the stone
when she's thrown from her course during
the falconry hunt
or have you at last come to consummate
our marriage
in House of the Dragon Damon causes her
horse to rear up and finishes the job of
the stone after she mocks him for his
impotence which is becoming a running
theme when it comes to the Rogue Prince
sir Kristen Cole might have admitted to
dalliances and his youth but that was
before he recorded his name in the white
book of The King's Guard and swore of
our Chastity whether he actually has
strong feelings for rhaenyra or is
merely more Pious and Rule following
than he let on the princess's White
Knight is desperate to absolve himself
of his sin some way somehow for a cias
rainera to run away with him rather than
Mary Elena or Valerian as she's been
commanded to do a marriage for love
when she suggests that he should be
happy enough as her lover and sworn
protector essentially asking him to
commit what he sees as Sin over and over
again he's disgusted by the idea and his
feelings and loyalties undergo a drastic
change that swing is made even more
pronounced when Queen Allison summons
him he reveals the truth and asks her to
give him the death penalty rather than
sentence him to gelding and torture sir
Kristen was right to worry we know for
Martin's writing that the kingsguard is
a lifetime appointment and punishment
for those who break their vows as
castration followed by a lifetime
sentence at the wall that Allison shows
Kristen Mercy both during his
questioning and in his moment of
hopelessness when he nearly takes his
own life will have made a strong
impression as a Targaryen without a
dragon king viserys is something of an
outlier so far we've seen Damon on
karaxi's rhaenyra on Cyrax and Lenor
who's half Targaryen on sea smoke
princess rhaenice is the most senior
Targaryen with the most Dragon riding
experience and in episode 5 we finally
get to see her mounted on her Dragon
Fire and Blood tells us that the dragon
is named melies and is also known as the
Red Queen so named for the beautiful
Rosy tint of her wings and scales she's
faster than karaxi's and originally
belonged to pasaris and Damon's mother
Queen Alyssa and both then princes took
their first dragon rides upon her back
when they were only days old the young
princess toured the Seven Kingdoms with
her grandfather King J Harris and she
rode the red queen to her own wedding
with Corliss when she was only about 16
years old it's a nice touch that the
show has her riding alongside Lenor and
route to her son's nuptials iron blood
is a fictional collected history
compiled from different sources who were
privy to different events in different
ways and who each had their own
political point of view and allegiances
the narrator whose accounts are often
the most detailed in scandalous is
mushroom a dwarf who served as fool to
King viserys's Court his physical
appearance three feet tall with an
oversized head and position as fool led
many in the nobility to assume that he
was intellectually disabled but he was
actually Savvy and observant fans of
Fire and Blood have had their fingers
crossed that we might get to see
mushroom as a character in House of the
Dragon no announcements to that effect
have been made however there is a
background character who fits mushroom's
description during rhaenyra and lenor's
wedding festivities he's wearing
Targaryen colors and playing music with
the rest of a band which is close enough
to a court jester he's even featured in
the teaser for episode 5. this is
probably just a wink to book readers but
our mystery man could come back to
record a story it's worth mentioning
that mushroom was quite fond of brain
era and thus his version would be
inclined to put her in a more favorable
light the costume in on House of the
Dragon isn't commended able just for its
stunning design and impeccable
construction the attire worn by King's
Landings movers and shakers is
significant and symbolic in Martin's
writing and so far the show is doing a
phenomenal job of illustrating that
I understand the queen is still readying
herself for the celebrations the single
most consequential piece of clothing
with literal life and death consequences
is Allison's green dress which makes its
debut in episode 5. she interrupts her
husband's wedding toast and Cat walks
through the throne room in an Exquisite
emerald green gown pulling all the
attention away from the rainian Monarch
in the air and bride to be Lara strong
asks his brother if he remembers what
color house Hightower uses in its Beacon
to call its people to war the answer is
green that means with this dress alicent
is effectively using fashion to fire the
first shots in the coming Targaryen
Civil War it's our unofficial
Proclamation that she does in fact want
her son aegon to be king the occasion
for which she wears the dress is a
change from the book and Fire and Blood
it's at her own fifth wedding
anniversary party with viserys that she
unveils her new look when in coming
episodes characters begin to align
themselves with the greens it's this
gown that gives their side its name
[Music]